okay let's see who else is holding on
today um buh buh buh let's go to the
seven eight six area code who's calling
from seven eight six today hello can you
hear me yeah we can this is Shawn hey
Shawn I was just I was just calling to
ask you to elaborate on something you
said on the Monday show okay when you
were talking about how Trump believed
Putin when he said North Korea did not
possess the missiles capable of hitting
the US mainland instead of believing our
own intelligence officials right he said
and I quote this is an existential
threat to the United States what do you
mean by existential threat and what you
believe that what I mean is that having
a president who seems to be so committed
ideologically to believing the
assertions of authoritarians around the
world over the assessments of our own
intelligence community has the potential
to or is in practice a national security
threat for the United States that's what
I'm okay because I was trying to
differentiate maybe you meant North
Korea specifically no not specifically I
mean listen you could you could have the
conversation about how much of an
existential threat is North Korea to the
US and of course there are people who
say it's a lot of bluster but they've
shown restraint for decades they're not
actually the existential threat some
make them out to be
but it's the more general just believing
Putin over our own intelligence okay
yeah that's what I was trying to
differentiate because I believed that
for a really long time that North Korea
it would be against their own interests
to really go all out with nuclear bombs
because it would share their own
destruction yeah I mean if you look at
the history of that there's this pattern
with North Korea where the famine gets
worse economic sanctions get worse and
then you start seeing bluster about
tests or procuring nuclear materials or
development or whatever and then
historically the way it goes is then we
up our aid a little bit and they sort of
back off a little bit but I agree with
you I mean there have not this we're now
in the third generation of Nohr
Korean regime that seems to understand
that it's sort of like mutually-assured
or at least assured self-destruction to
actually bomb the US or whatever yes all
right thank you for elaborating on that
okay appreciate the call thank you so
much